[Music]
now where to begin
my mother named me anola
[Music]
which backwards spells alone
and yet we were always together
and it was wonderful she was my whole
world
which leads me on to the second thing
you need to know a week ago i awoke
mother to find that my mother was
missing
and she did not return i'm presently on
the way to collect my brothers
mycroft and sherlock yes sherlock holmes
the famous detective my genius brother
he will have all the answers
where's your hat in your gloves well i
have a hat just makes my head itch
and i have no gloves my god a wild woman
brought up
a wild child who will make her
acceptable for society
she seems intelligent there are two
pearls you can take an era
yours or the path others choose for you
it is time to find my mother the game is
a foot
if i have to stay hidden from my
brothers
i must become something
a unexpected
[Music]
you've progressed nicely
is she safe she's had company i'm vice
camp chugspray a useless boy
you have to help me i'm not ready to die
on a train i'm not ready to die at all
and i wasn't going to before i met you
what are you planning mother
she always had a reason for everything
her own way of doing things perhaps she
wants to change the world
perhaps it's a world that needs changing
come on unlike most well-bred ladies i
was never taught to embroider
i was taught to watch and listen
i was taught to fight i'm coming to find
you mother
you don't know how to embroider
back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new sherlock holmes trailer for
henry cavill's new
sherlock holmes it's called enola homes
because millie bobby brown is playing
that character i'll explain what's going
on
and where it fits into the larger
sherlock holm cannon because most of you
will remember benedict cumberbatch
sherlock holmes or robert downey jr's
sherlock holmes
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite version of
sherlock on the video
if you've been a subscriber of my
channel for a couple years now you
probably remember i did episode videos
for the benedict cumberbatch sherlock
series it seems like it's been a long
time but it actually hasn't been that
long
i will rank all of the sherlocks but
this is basically like your big netflix
crossover between the witcher
and stranger things sam claflin is
playing mycroft homes and helena bottom
carter is playing her mother
but this is a movie it's not a tv series
there was some confusion about that when
they first dropped this trailer
the reason the movie is called enola
holmes is because the movie is based on
a more recent sherlock holmes book
series from the perspective of a nola
holmes character
the holmes sister the movie's plot is
taken from a story called the case of
the missing marquis and the
series itself spans six novels covering
the period between anola's 14th and 15th
birthdays so she's like the 14 year old
sister of sherlock holmes in mycroft
homes
the basic premise of the movie is that
enola holmes mother helena bonham carter
seemingly disappears so she calls her
brothers sherlock and mycroft holmes for
help who just kind of dismiss her as
this unimportant 14 year old girl like
you're a little girl in victorian london
go be a little girl as you see during
the trailer they try to send her off to
a boarding school where she won't cause
them any problems because sherlock
holmes
is in full sherlock holmes mode being
the detective that everybody knows
when the events of this movie pick up
he's already been active as a detective
for a long time he's become very famous
but an old holmes boltz tries to find
her mother on her own and then starts
running into a lot of people from the
sherlock holmes stories like lestrade
she winds up getting caught up in a case
that sherlock is currently working on
involving a vi count
she finds him that's the young boy
that's running around with her in the
trailer the vi count that sherlock has
been looking for
so as they're busy trying to escape the
people that tried to kidnap
them she finds out what happens to her
mother and then goes on to a career as a
detective on her own
i don't know if they plan on doing any
sequels to this i think it just depends
on how successful it is and how much
people like
henry cavill as sherlock holmes i'm
really fascinated to see what his
version of sherlock is going to be like
but you might remember that in the
original arthur conan doyle sherlock
holmes canon there is no mention of a
holmes sister
then they reveal the existence of their
secret sister who's been
institutionalized in a maximum security
prison her whole life
and she's so brilliant that she makes
mycroft seem dumb by comparison
so this enola holmes with millie bobby
brown is sort of a twist on that conceit
henry cavill's version of sherlock per
this book series that it's based on
is as eccentric as you'd expect sherlock
to be but he's still the most personable
of the brothers or the holmes children
and minecraft might be smarter but
socially he doesn't have a clue to make
as many sherlock puns as possible
and at least within the context of these
anola holmes stories that the movie is
based on the 14 year old anola is sort
of a rising star
not quite as brilliant or experienced as
sherlock yet but showing signs of
promise
and because she's a 14 year old girl she
still has to contend with all the
awkward comedy of being a 14 year old
girl
in victorian era london so it's very
much 11 from stranger things
but make it sherlock holmes even though
the benedict cumberbatch version of
sherlock was a contemporary series set
during present day
they did do a christmas special where
they did an episode as if it were taking
place during the original period of the
sherlock holmes novels back during
victorian era london
i think if you're a fan of henry cavill
and millie bobby brown on stranger
things this is probably something for
you
if you're hardcore sherlock holmes fan
you'll probably be able to spot all the
non-canonical stuff a mile away
so this movie is a very very loose
adaptation of the canon
there are some easter eggs for a lot of
sherlock holmes arthur conan doyle stuff
but the actual stories that the movie is
taken from are not canon themselves
i haven't seen much of henry cavill's
non-justice league superman work
recently besides the witcher netflix but
i did like him during that and it is fun
to see him do other stuff
i think when he signed with netflix for
the witcher netflix they were like
please
do other things with us other big
projects so you'll probably see henry
cavill show up on more netflix movies
every once in a while
they are busy filming the witcher
netflix season 2 right now
i just posted the witcher season 2
teaser trailer because there was news
about jason momoa
joining the witcher netflix i'll add a
link for that in the description and at
the end of the video here
i think millie bobby brown is definitely
a rising star i kind of wanted her to do
a young princess leia star wars disney
plus series after stranger things was
over
but i think lucasfilm is kind of staying
away from doing something like that for
a while maybe eventually we'll see her
show up in the star wars movies
and speaking of stranger things they're
busy finishing filming
stranger things season four right now i
just did a stranger things season five
video because the duffer brothers
confirmed that they would be doing
stranger things season five so also add
a link for that at the end of this if
you're a big stranger things fan
but just ranking all the versions of
sherlock recently so far
so we have robert danny jr sherlock
who's totally solid
he himself in real life is just as
eccentric as the sherlock holmes
character so it's a perfect fit
game of shadows wasn't quite as good as
the first movie he did but they are
still planning on making a sherlock 3
movie at some point in the next few
years they've already announced it but i
don't know when that's actually going to
premiere
but benedict cumberbatch i think is
still the superior version of a sherlock
story
mostly because they had many many hours
to develop that character through four
seasons of the show
some of the seasons were a little
disappointing but at the end of the day
i think if you're looking for the
maximum
version of sherlock he's the one that
was by that scene during avengers
infinity war with them facing off with
so much fun
of course it would have been too much
for them to actually mention sherlock
during that
but it was so much fun just watching
those two different versions of sherlock
have that gunslinger moment stand off
with each other
if we don't do our jobs what is your job
exactly besides making balloon animals
protecting your reality douchebag okay
guys
both of them are fans of each other's
portrayal of sherlock holmes robert
downey jr was a fan of the sherlock
series and benedict cumberbatch very
graciously was also a fan of the
sherlock holmes movies that robert
downey jr did
the henry cavill sherlock holmes movie
is going to be dropping september 23rd
stranger things season four is probably
going to be released sometime towards
the end of next year
as is probably the witcher season two
but they haven't
officially confirmed release dates for
those other two series but i will do
videos for those when we get more
information
everyone click here for that witcher
season 2 teaser trailer
and click here for that stranger things
season 4 trailer in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight